look at how a game of Thrones just ended
I personally was quite happy with how
Game of Thrones ended but a lot of
people online bitching and moaning about
the ending are you these snowflakes
bitchin and moanin we just be happy you
got Game of Thrones in the first yes
that's what I say seriously yeah do you
know how you would like it to end
Silicon Valley let's put it that way I
know that you and this is not a spoiler
because you have no control over these
things you are you were but the actor
you were but the puppet I am a humble a
humble puppet a humble cog in this
machine I I hope as I spit I hope that
it'll be in some way bittersweet much
like the show everything every victory
has like a thing
anytime something good happens for those
guys it's immediately followed by a
downfall every time there's a downfall
there's something good so they're
they're very good at doing that so show
is perpetually going yeah we did it
while someone runs by and goes haha I
got you in the nuts yeah that's the show
and not in a pleasurable way no believe
you me because when you first set it up
as I go is only right it's a win-win
hello hello get to the bad part